yo hello and welcome to this video I am
van nostrand so let's experiment a
little bit and see what happens I had a
look at this line just today but like
for a couple of minutes so I don't
really claim any knowledge i was
thinking him why was i have to say i was
checking some Sicilian lines and this
was one of them so there is Sir 95
threatened hmm oh yeah that's not ideal
right
hmm 95 not happy about Quincy seven here
oh wow I totally forgot to forget it
forgot about this idea who yeah that's
great that's great
yeah it's a total loss sir you cannot
even fight great brilliant brilliant
brilliant oh my god those I really hate
those games for you just give a piece
for nothing and give it away the point
yeah many things win of course for him
you
and you can just take a seven amongst
amongst others also take f six then
Queenie for many moves when I've
blundered a piece
now also they're very simple stuff it's
not playing him for what reason I don't
know
I can take and check me as the problem
yeah whatever what I could have resigned
but i don't know i don't like to
especially in games where my opponent
like he didn't need to show anything i
mean just through a mother's gift always
hate that so i continue i know maybe
he's got something very bad moment does
it look like it at all an ITEX of seven
is actually pretty good check check
you can take the bishop even even this
is nate know whatever check check check
check mate yeah what an idiotic game
yeah just gifting him the piece there
yeah it's a little bit of awkward gee I
mean I really have no idea about the
theoretical details here this is this a
certainly normal position and maybe it's
played differently from here I don't
know it's a little bit awkward now with
this 95 IDM this is of course just a
joke it's easy to win I have absolutely
no chance here whatsoever check check
many many ways lead to win check check
check Queen h8 also check oops checkmate
yeah what's also quite good yeah what
can you do this game is easy to
understand don't blunder piece very very
bad yeah what is it that I should play
engine gives this I don't quite
understand I mean maybe yeah okay maybe
you can flag is but the clicks oh
there's this point
okay so that means that 95 isn't so
dangerous at least okay that that's a
very tough move to play if you don't
know it then you'd wants to play this
and gives widen advantage possible yeah
I was just experimenting with this
opening but that was probably not a good
idea poor ok guys thanks for watching